bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro cordero
Este 16 de octubre se cumple el 60
aniversario del que probablemente fue el
momento más crítico de la guerra fría la
crisis de los misiles en Cuba entre
Estados Unidos y la unión soviética 13
días en los que las dos potencias
estuvieron al borde de llegar a una
guerra nuclear en francés 24 repasamos
todos los detalles de este episodio de
La historia con motivo de su aniversario
la crisis comenzó el 16 de octubre de
1962 cuando en la mañana de ese día el
ex presidente John fitzgerald Kennedy
fue informado por su asesor Mac George
bundy de que en los días previos un
avión U2 estadounidense había tomado
varias fotos de lo que parecían bases
soviéticas con misiles de medio alcance
en la isla de Cuba
Estados Unidos había sido durante
décadas el principal benefactor de la
economía cubana especialmente a través
de la importación de azúcar sin embargo
su relación con esta nación se había
deteriorado tras la revolución que llevó
a Fidel Castro al poder en 1959 dos años
después el gobierno cubano consiguió
frustrar un intento de invasión de
opositores alentado por Estados Unidos
El llamado desembarque de bahía cochinos
y Castro había logrado esquivar varios
intentos de terminar con su vida para
deponerlo del poder algo que había
elevado la desconfianza de los nuevos
líderes revolucionarios hacia Estados
Unidos y que inevitablemente los había
acercado hacia su mayor rival La Unión
soviética
una situación que comprometía seriamente
la seguridad estadounidense
Especialmente cuando en 1962 la URSS
ofreció a Cuba ser su principal socio
comercial y protección a cambio de
instalar una serie de misiles en la isla
estos proyectiles tenían la capacidad de
recorrer casi 2.000 km una distancia que
ponía a tiro a ciudades estadounidenses
como Washington DC Atlanta o Nueva
Orleans pero a pesar de la gravedad del
acontecimiento en un comienzo el mundo
no fue consciente de lo que estaba
sucediendo y solamente lo sabía el
círculo más cercano al presidente John
fitzgerald Kennedy durante esos primeros
días una docena de asesores y el mismo
presidente debatieron sobre cómo
responder y las divisiones fueron
constantes mientras el mando militar
apostaba por atacar de forma sorpresiva
otra parte de las personas de confianza
de Kennedy apostó por aplicar la
diplomacia junto a Duros de contención y
es esta postura la que triunfó una vez
se concretó la respuesta el presidente
Kennedy se dirigió a la nación casi seis
días después de ser conocedor de la
crisis
en la última semana pruebas
inconfundibles han establecido el hecho
de que se está preparando una serie de
bases de misiles ofensivas en la isla de
Cuba mandar
el propósito de estas bases no puede ser
otro que el de proporcionar una
capacidad de ataque nuclear contra el
hemisferio occidental
la reacción inmediata estadounidense
consistió en impedir que pudiera llegar
más armamento a Cuba desde la URSS por
lo que se decretó un bloqueo naval a
toda la isla en su discurso Kennedy
trató de advertir a la unión soviética
de la peligrosidad que suponía para
ambos el entrar en guerra y el usar
armas nucleares en ella
las armas nucleares son tan destructivas
y los misiles balísticos tan rápidos que
cualquier posibilidad sustancialmente
mayor de su uso o cualquier cambio
repentino en su despliegue puede
considerarse una amenaza para la paz
la respuesta inicial de la unión
soviética fue negativa y Durante los
siguientes días se vislumbró el inicio
del conflicto nuclear ante el avance de
buques soviéticos hacia Cuba a pesar del
bloqueo naval en estas horas de máxima
atención jugaron un papel clave las
negociaciones secretas entre los
diplomáticos de los dos países
de todos estos esfuerzos destaca
especialmente el del periodista de la
cadena estadounidense ABC John scally y
el del Coronel del kgb Alexander foming
quienes intercambiaron mensajes críticos
entre los dos gobiernos scalli fue
fundamental para la desescalada porque
en una de sus respuestas afirmó al
contacto soviético que la invasión sobre
Cuba estaba próxima a pesar de que el
gobierno estadounidense no le autorizó
contarlo algo que hizo que la URSS
acelerase para encontrar una solución y
esa solución le llegó a Kennedy de forma
directa por parte del líder soviético
Nikita crochet y en el 28 de octubre le
propuso al presidente estadounidense
desmantelar los misiles en Cuba A cambio
de que Estados Unidos se comprometiera a
no invadir la isla y a desmantelar los
misiles balísticos instalados en Turquía
e Italia entre 1958 y 1959 armas que
suponían para la unión soviética la
misma amenaza que los misiles de Cuba
tenían para Estados Unidos
el acuerdo fue verbal pero Kennedy lo
aceptó a pesar de que un día antes la
guerra estuvo a punto de iniciar cuando
un avión espía estadounidense fue
derribado en Cuba el desmantelamiento de
los misiles de Estados Unidos en Italia
y Turquía se mantuvo en secreto pero en
las dos partes cumplieron el acuerdo
algo que relajó la tensión a partir del
29 de octubre en estas negociaciones
quedó fuera el gobierno cubano quien
criticó la política de Nikita cruzchef
ya que apostaba por un ataque hacia
Estados Unidos por miedo hacia una
invasión de este pero sus posturas
finalmente no fueron tomadas en cuenta
este fue el final del que pudiera haber
sido uno de los peores episodios en la
historia de la humanidad un momento de
máxima tensión en el que se llegó a
contemplar una guerra nuclear que habría
supuesto la destrucción de estas dos
potencias y que probablemente habría
puesto en peligro la continuidad del ser
humano como una especie con esto
concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]